well you smile about it you like to
crush another man's ego uh-huh so when
they go home that night you know they
know and then they can't kid themselves
that they're so hot you know where do
you get your
confidence well when you're successful
you realize there must be something
going on mean why why am I so successful
there must be a reason right so
obviously there's something some some
natural ability some factors working
right is chess a tough game for the body
as well as the mind it is pretty tough
yeah cuz of all the tension all the uh
lot of concentration sitting there for
hour after hour it's real exhausting I
think that that's pretty difficult for
somebody who doesn't know the game to
understand it looks like I mean after
all you and I sit at a board yeah well
you know it's kind of like after you go
into to take your you know your final
exam or something you're pretty tired
right so it's like taking a 5H hour exam
every day or something